good evening I'm Matthew Spalding I'm
associate vice president Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
welcome to Albuquerque Center for
Constitutional studies and citizenship
our lecture tonight is in association
with the hundredth anniversary of an
important event and in the true
Hillsdale way we try to think through
what is the best way to have that kind
of conversation but of course through
great thinkers and in discussing the our
topic this evening about the Russian
Revolution we are looking through the
eyes of Marx Lenin and souls and eats in
a man who influenced man who was in the
middle of and a man who suffered under
but the other thing that's important for
tonight is that we were interested in
having a talk about ideas in this way
and it just so happens that one of our
great professors from campus teaches
this subject and I'm happy to say is a
colleague and a good friend of mine and
I'm very happy to have him here I
learned early he's never been to
Washington DC before which is a
remarkable thing and I'm way time after
a few drinks I'll get the real story as
is our tradition we have one of our
current students introduce our speaker
more formally David doors a junior
studying politics in history he's on the
WIPP program working for representative
Mike Bishop on campus he's part of the
few good min program at Hillsdale
created community focused volunteer
group he's a member of Pi Alpha Theta
History honorary and among other things
while he's here in Washington C he's
taking my class on statesmanship and
will be tested based on his how well he
does this evening so David
[Applause]
I want to thank dr. Spaulding for his
kind words and want to preemptively um
express my sorrow for disappointing him
I have the honor today of introducing
dr. John grant he's an associate
professor of politics at Hillsdale
College after earning his Bachelor of
Arts a Eureka College in Illinois he
went on to receive his master's and PhD
from the University of Dallas he is also
an adjunct fellow at the Claremont
Institute for the Study of statesmanship
and political philosophy and he is also
a contributor to toured an American
conservatism the birth of constitutional
conservatism during the Progressive Era
please join me in welcoming dr. John
Graham thank you all for being here and
and as Matt mentioned I avoid large
cities as a rule in Washington DC in
particular and I mean no offense when I
say that but the just a few blocks of
traffic getting here rattled my nerves
like oh my god and like I want to get
back to Hillsdale where if you stopped
at a light it's a frustration you know I
think this is terrible I had to stop
once at a stoplight okay so I'm going to
talk about as Matt mentioned marshland
and souls needs to know the meaning of
the Russian Revolution and I'll start
I'm not known for my great humility but
I will have to admit some limitations
here one I have no Russian some of you
I'm in Washington DC they're my people
here actually speak Russian and that you
know so the works of souls and eats them
that have not been translated and those
are there's a few of those I haven't had
the opportunity to read and I'm also not
an expert on the Russian Revolution
itself I'm more interested in souls in
each sense view I mean I know something
about it and if you have a question I'll
try and relate that to how that works
and then the the last and perhaps most
dishonorable I feel a little derpy so if
I miss something I have a five month old
daughter who's wonderful she's the first
night ever she decided basically not to
sleep at all last night usually she
sleeps eight solid hours so I
two hours sleep and how did you I like
to fly flatter myself she's upset that
I'm leaving her and she wanted but I've
probably just gas or something so if you
notice any you didn't talk about some
you feel free to bring that up I became
interested in Marxism and souls Neeson
over twenty years ago when I was a grad
student for two reasons
Minh Assad because my own case is
interesting but because I think it's
good reasons for being interested in
this topic
one is that Marxism as it was worked in
the USSR is an exemplary instance of
ideological tyranny I mean it's it's
there's a lot of if you really want to
see what is it but a tyranny that wants
to get into people's souls I mean there
been tyrannies around forever you know
the classics talk about tyrannies Plato
Aristotle what have you but IDIA logical
tyranny of the that's the new thing and
I'll say more about what that means
Souls and second Solzhenitsyn is a great
help in grasping not only the nature of
Marx's tyranny but the spiritual crisis
of our time and the last six months or
so so I've really been thinking about is
why do we do some of the insane things
we do you can't explain as a matter of
policy difference or something like that
and and the three authors I think are
most helpful in getting some answers to
this question our souls and Eason
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky especially in
his demons and brothers karamazov and I
would put souls in Easton at the rank of
a Nietzsche or Dostoevsky and they're
different they have differences amongst
each other but is a great thinker the
hard part about studying Souls in each
son and his in trying to see how he
understood the Russian Revolution and
the events subsequent to that for us is
you know in some of you probably read
the Gulag Archipelago I know around a
bunch of well-educated people here it's
this long horror story right of this how
do people how do people endure this
shorter versions this is one day in the
life of Ivan Denisovich and souls and
eaten while portraying the horror in
you might remember this if you had a
chance to read the huge three volumes or
one of the abridged versions is he blast
prison thanked it which is kind of a
remarkable thing considering the take
you know eight years in brutal
conditions almost died of cancer almost
died a number of times because it made
him think he was a Marxist when he was
sent away he was he he didn't like
Stalin but he was a believing Marxist
and it made him confront things and made
him think about God he'd never really
taken it seriously he'd accepted the
Marxist indoctrination about that that
God is just a religion in general just
lie to appease the masses and keep them
from knowing their misery and throwing
off their chains and so now I'm really
thankful that we don't have
concentration camps here and the other
really kind of terrible necessity in our
lives but it also makes it really hard
to really try and figure things like
this out from the comfort of our of our
lives I mean I marvel at central I
believe this is air conditioning I'm
coming where the heat was just on but
it's great I mean and and but it makes
us soft I don't wanna get rid of it but
it does it is an impediment to thought
not air conditioning per se but just you
know DC the capital of the probably the
most powerful nation the world has ever
seen but poor Americans live lives a
Roman Emperor would envy in terms of the
luxury so it's it's have a friend a
mutual friend dr. Spaulding on a man
named John Murray nice oft times are
hard times in cases of thought if you're
trying to think you know that's I think
that's very well put but despite the
wonders of the times we live in you know
the modern medicine comfort wealth all
these things we there's still a lot of
rot in our country and I'm and that
won't be a surprise to hear it probably
from this podium a lot of problems and a
lot of things superficially you know yes
there's great wealth there's also
depending on how you count it between
twenty and a hundred trillion dollars
and debt you know so things like that
okay so that there's a weak
not just intellectual curiosity then
although that's a good thing that would
drive us to figure this out but we need
to understand what tyranny is what
especially ideological tyranny and it's
dangerous even today and in trying I
always think it's imperative to make any
time I speak with students for another
group it has to be useful for life
otherwise that you're just kind of you
know you might as well give a talk on
stamp collecting or butterflies or but
you all find things but really who cares
at the end of the day baseball cards
whatever is it has to why why should we
care about this and the objection I
think and an obvious objection to why
would we care about the Russian
Revolution and Marxism or souls Neeson's
view of it this hundred-year-old event I
mean we won the Cold War right that's
the and there's not that many Marxist
around there are people who are
officially Marxist still floating around
but they don't I don't think they really
mean it I mean China is not really a
communist country in any meaningful
they're not looking forward to the
classless society and neither was Hugo
Chavez has been as way lower or North
Korea or what have you but
post-modernism and its attendant
problems are very much dominant today
and are related to Marxism we're all try
and make that case so try and say
something about this in a nutshell and
you know feel free to press me on this
in the QA what post-modernism does is
deny that it's possible and I mean
people like Richard Rorty leotard
Jacques Derrida it's the deny that it's
possible to get at truth with a capital
T you might so you might be able to know
contingent facts to use rorty's language
or something like that but they don't
they don't tell you anything about how
to live you can't get a just and unjust
out of this you guys know richard
rorty's is probably the most prominent
american academic philosopher in recent
times died maybe ten years ago now and
all that all all these facts are merely
contingent phenomena that don't attach
to any larger meaning and don't tell us
what justice is or how to live so you're
left with with prejudice and rory says
well I hope that you have
good prejudices like you want to be kind
to people but when pressed well can you
give a reason not to be a Nazi he says
no no I just hope you won't because I
don't like it it's not my preference and
that's a pretty disturbing place to be
and intellectually and it's it's not
just roaring those handful of thinkers
if you want to entertain yourself
there's a great Twitter feed you I don't
even tweet but you can look these things
up on the internet new it's called real
peer review you should you should really
look at this it'll make you laugh or cry
depending on your mood but and these
young academics pseudonymous of course
because this gets them in trouble they
take the abstracts from real
peer-reviewed articles and I've
discovered there's an entire new field
of academia which is a bunch of Auto
ethnography which means you describe how
you feel about stuff and and this gets
this is good
people have always done this right
that's fine but how do you peer-review
someone else's feelings and and it's
badly written too is they're not even
doing good grammar checks usually but
you know but it makes sense well that's
all you've got is your feelings is your
preferences your prejudices there's no
there's no other no other guide to wife
to tell you how to will and so the
consequence of this is some type of
obscurantism or I've got my truth that
I'm either too taking this phrase from
the German American Thinker Leo's trials
took a fanatical obscurantism and the
introduction to this book city and man
just a threat in his time that was over
fifty years ago
where I've got my own private truth and
I'm going to shove it down everybody
else's throat well that's one the other
is not fanatical we're just pursue
pleasure and and and do whatever you
want heedless of the common good and the
two-tire not necessarily opposed to each
other
Harvey Weinstein comes to mind is
someone who combined both you know
relentless ideological propaganda on
behalf of modern liberalism and utmost
degradation in his personal life and
what would a Richard Rorty or most
modern American academics have to say
about why that's bad they couldn't
really give any answer except
say they don't like it an tyfa and that
you know that's that's fanatical
obscurantism there they don't even have
a plan that the marxist at least had a
vision of the future evil but here's how
we're gonna get there here's what the
end is to the classless society we're no
human being oppresses any other human
being the anti-fog is tearing stuff down
but from what I can tell and on closer
to home because I doubt there's many any
Foss sympathizers in the room but we
have just meaningless stupid slogans
like being on the right side of history
it's just drivel that means nothing and
it's dangerous because it empowers well
we got to do this because we're on the
right side of history or nation-building
how's that going you know it's just the
slogan we keep hearing about without
much content or sanity so but that's my
view that's that's the that's it those
are those are terms that come in our
intellectual framework now you know they
talked about a lot they're out there and
so what Solzhenitsyn shows us and I'm
thinking especially of his Gulag
Archipelago and his beautiful novel in
the first circle that despite scientific
pretensions that the marxist had so for
instance Engels in his eulogy of Marx
compared him to Darwin and just as
Darwin had discovered the law supposedly
of evolution of non-human life
especially in Engels account Marx that
understood the real motor of human
history class conflict and that's a
scientific true observation and so a lot
of academic accounts of Marxism stressed
that side of Marxism if you've ever
soldiered through if you you know you're
mad at yourself or you've got a child
you want to punish like a 17 year old
make them breed parts of desk happy tall
or Marxist Grund risa it's grim stuff
and but the claim is these are
scientific accounts of how the economy
works and what that means for human life
and so that's that's there certainly
Engels like to talk about scientific
socialism I'm not a utopian dreamer I'm
we marks and I understand scientific or
true socialism is but I think what souls
and Eastin shows us is despite those
pretensions Marxism Bolshevism is really
at its core based on the obscure insist
denial of the possibility of there being
a god or a higher being that can tell us
what to do or constrain our will and the
possibility of any truth and some some
slogans that souls need some likes to
use to exemplify this taken from the
Russian Bolsheviks Soviet Bolsheviks
nature we will teach freedom we will
reach was one of them in other words
we're going to conquer nature and this
is especially there's this part of the
Gulag Archipelago where he talks about
these forced labor projects which were
done with basically maybe Bronze Age
tools the tens of thousands of political
prisoners would be sent out in the
winter to build a canal for instance the
White Sea canal were many almost all of
them perished of course they're using
wooden wheelbarrows on you know ground
that was and hand tools and ground was
frozen three feet deep and he thought
what that showed they're not really
interested in science you're not you're
you just think if you just apply enough
will you'll transform the given souls
Newton also talks about the gulag as the
Soviet sewage disposal system that's
because our sewage disposal system and
he uses that metaphor because of course
sewage is that's nasty stuff that would
be poisonous but you treat it and it
becomes benign and so the point of the
forced labor camps was not directly
death although there was an awful lot of
that a very great deal of it it was the
creation of the new Soviet man helping
to bring about the classless society the
utopian ideal the idea being you are you
have these antisocial thoughts you're
not willing to pull in the harness for
the common good and so we're going to
strip you of everything and Marx like to
talk about how the proletariat which is
the class that has nothing and so they
they that's why they're the rebel
shanira class would guided by the party
driven by people like Marx and well the
the concentration camps were meant to to
do that and the whole career of souls
and Easton he's not the only one I mean
there are quite a few intelligent
dissidents who rebelled against that
proves that that can't work it's
willfully shoving we're gonna force you
into this mold and make you what we want
that's not going to happen well it can
happen but it's not going to produce the
desired result
so yet the the the attempt to remake
nature and especially human nature was
was practiced by Lenin and Stalin and
advocated by Marx and that's often
denied by academics academics which is
kind of astonishing because Marx talked
about how you need revolutionary terror
you need to violate booze wah wah you
should use labor forced labor as a means
of social corrective and works like his
critique of the Gulf the program and
address to the Central Committee he also
never finished desk capitalist he kept
trying to foment revolution I mean it's
kind of a nice anecdote that shows you
how he thought about the place of
science versus revolutionary activity so
to switch gears to two souls and Eastin
on the revolution I'm trying to
summarize he's got so far in English
three volumes these massive volumes
August 1914 November 1916 and the first
part of March 1917 it's about
twenty-five twenty-six hundred pages
altogether I think kind of defy their
kind of like historical novels but that
doesn't quite do them justice they're
mix of history and fiction meant to show
you what the revolution was like so I'm
gonna try and summarize this in a couple
of paragraphs so you know and I thought
it made me think about its hopefully
that hopefully it's helpful what one of
the things Souls needs and sets out to
prove is there was no inevitability to
the Bolshevik Revolution which is the
Marxist claim that one of the
fundamental Marxist claims you have to
have the revolution because of the
contradictions that are within
capitalism itself the souls in each
scens
portrayal he does not he's not using the
second and didactic treatise he just
shows these different actors most of
them historical some of them fictional
that Russia's history and the choices of
a large number of people at the time and
not dialectical materialism into the
Marxist claim and class conflict brought
the revolution into being and just for
some examples August 1914 is is mostly
about the rush the Russian German Battle
of Tannenberg the opening of world war
one where the Russians launched a hasty
offensive at the request of the French
to slow down the German onslaught in the
West that divert resources was the idea
and in the course of this this very
amazing portrait of the battle and the
characters in it Souls Neeson shows they
could have beat the Germans look what
have happened at that battle was it it
was it was a very plausible thing there
was a few choices made at particular
points especially the character of the
general who is a this not the kind of
general you want he was a Tolstoy and
fatalist he didn't believe human beings
could affect events you know that's you
I can you can't be on the Joint Chiefs
of Staff if you think Tolstoy was right
you know in war and peace about this
this is a problem but nobody checked
that box on the application and it's
it's more complicated than that but that
was a part of it
even then they almost won and think that
in other words the war might have gone
very differently and without Russian
participation in the war souls Nissen
depicts a great length you would never
had the Bolshevik Revolution you had
massive numbers of Russians dying for no
apparent purpose and the instability the
anger at the regime and the instability
who aided the Bolsheviks you also have
the this character I'll say a little bit
more about him momentarily
Peter Stolypin who was
Nicholas the seconds Prime Minister
interior minister and Prime Minister
between 1906 and 1908
so the period after the revolution 1905
and some of you may know and somebody
may not there was a revolution 1905 that
almost brought the regime down narrowly
fended off its dilip in what is
portrayed by souls in each sin as a sort
of model statesman who began this
program of political reform and I'll say
more about the details but that if that
had been allowed to carry out and still
even also thought Russia's Imperial
ventures were catastrophic and he would
oppose intervention in World War one and
behalf of the Western powers it was the
one of the precipitating factors in the
1905 revolution was the Russian defeat
at the hands of the Japanese in the 1904
1905 war which dilip and thought why are
we fighting the Japanese over Manchuria
we don't need Matt we don't this is bad
and the Tsar would listen to him for a
time and the thought was well perhaps
his advice could have prevailed later
these examples to show there wasn't this
didn't have to happen
they also had a very weak czar I mean
nicholas ii was a really kind of a nice
fellow who meant well but hated to make
decisions and when you're in the regime
that's crumbling and fighting a world
war that's not it's right up there with
the Tolstoy in general that's a matter
of choice there are chance excuse me
there's no historical inevitability that
the last Tsar will be only
semi-competent and weak-willed the
particular history of the Russian
intelligentsia the the intellectual
class are all thought and this is one of
the most important parts I think of
souls Neeson's portrayal to revolution
they all agreed on two things that the
Tsar had to go because anything else
would be better all the educated people
in Russia just knew we couldn't do worse
than the Tsar we can see that was really
really really mistaken right but it's
just kind of obviously a stupid view you
know those of us paying attention might
have noticed that man Llumar Gaddafi was
really bad Libya is worse now I mean
there's there's worse than nutty nuts
guys who'd like to have a mazzani and
bodyguards running around them and
there's worse there's chaos there
massive refugee crises of the reopening
of slave markets these are some things
that have you know but the Obama
administration just knew will bring will
bring democracy does no problem it's
what could possibly go wrong that's one
of my favorite phrases you guys might
hear this is what these pop culture
phrases what could possibly go wrong and
I keep thinking that about so many
things our government does in sarcastic
it's obviously gonna work out so
intelligent all the intellectuals we
know the Tsar has to go and what will
happen is western-style parliamentary
democracy that's just going to happen
[Music]
it's still still not happening in Russia
you know 100 years later and by the way
that's something I'd be happy to talk
about in the Q&A if we want to talk
about souls in need since views of Putin
in the contemporary situation I'll do my
best with that but the other thing so
the Czar's gotta go the other thing was
we have to continue the war with Germany
and this you know why and we don't talk
much I mean time most of you unless you
had some kind of Advanced Study don't
read much about what did it mean to be a
Russian fighting on against the Germans
led by semi competent officers and human
wave attacks
it was dispiriting their losses were
very great and they were the best of the
society and that people will talk about
this in relation to the the you know
people who died on the Somme or Verdun
or what have you
yeap but well a lot of Russians who were
loyal to the regime and decent the type
of people that didn't shirk service or
trying to become a government bureaucrat
to avoid being sent to the front where
they were the type of people put into
the meat grinder one of the things that
made the the fall of the Czar possible
was he had sent his own
regiments to the front he didn't hold
him back so sort of palace guard you
know so that when they came back they
were all chewed up and unable to resist
very well by the time they got there so
that but you don't have to have an
intelligence you like that and by the
way I think this is very relevant for us
and especially in a town when I wear
what was Hillary's about 93% and DC I
mean ninety-six sorry you know wow
that's a lot of powerful people with a
very homogeneous viewpoint maybe that's
not always a good thing
that would have been a very bad thing I
hope I don't know but you guys but I'm
really enjoying I'm just reading the
articles about that Donna Brazile book
and it's just it's just warmed the
cockles of my tiny heart okay I digress
I'm sorry and so also you have the the
Bolsheviks had this had to have a
tremendous amount of luck the real
success of the Bolsheviks was in souls
in each sense account made possible by
the karinski government the provisional
government of kind of moderate liberals
the constitutional democrats the cadets
is the is the but that doesn't really
say much that doesn't meet with the
military and yes they wanted
western-style liberal democracy but they
had a very great softness for
bomb-throwing revolutionaries does this
sound familiar you know I'm kind of
tired of seeing people who you know
dudes the kind of stuff auntie fog does
don't get prosecuted all too often
that's kind of why is that
that's anyway this is bad so this this
that really guaranteed the success of
the Bolsheviks which was this tiny
splinter group who had one thing going
for them which was the iron will and the
linen who had perfected over decades of
splitting the party you might think his
revolutionary you'd want to get as many
people involved as you could that was
never Lenin's thing it was always you
have to agree with me I'll purge you
I'll purge you I'll purge you and souls
and Easton has a book called from these
these these books about the world war
one called linen and Zurich whereas
this portrayal of Lenin that he's
sitting when he had 15 followers in
Zurich he'd be excommunicating people
for you you're not disagreeing with
Bernstein and the Social Democrats
enough you get out you know and you
how's this gonna lead to success and
perversely it did because he he didn't
waver everybody else kind of dithering
and wavering and you know karinski and
his people especially and London had
many many terrible defects but being
lacking focus was not one of them but
that was that didn't have to happen
either you know if you hadn't had linin
there who in many ways was kind of a
comically incompetent figure also if he
hadn't had the help of Germany getting
him back into the country you know yet
to get from Switzerland Germany another
historical accident so there was nothing
that things happened Souls needs insane
because of predominantly because of too
that the circumstances which do exercise
a coercive effect on things the Russian
intelligentsia had been opposed to the
Tsar for probably 7080 years you know
since the Decembrists were prominent
that was not going to go away anytime
soon that's something that's going to
have in effect but then you still have
all these other choices that that had to
be made have that come out so the idea
that well there's an inevitability to
this because of the defects of
capitalism that's not that's not borne
out by the evidence to go back to Marx
Lenin and Stalin I put it a few minutes
ago Marx advocated this stuff and Lenin
and Stalin carried it out so it's very
common in in the scholarship to see
Stalin wasn't a real Marxist he was a
deviation as he would he wanted a cult
of personality was one of the terms that
came and maybe Lenin too depending on
who you're talking to but Marx was a was
a hugging unicorns and and dancing after
rainbows kind of guy and it could
meaning the class of society will come
about inexorably because of economic
factors and you won't need to have these
terrible blood baths and now
and souls and Eason says shows that's
just flat wrong and he especially does
this in the gulag archipelago where you
quotes Marx and we're advocating this
kind of stuff and then goes into great
detail about the terroristic measures
employed by Lenin mass murder
concentration all the features for which
Stalinism is famous were part of the
Leninist regime let Stalin just built on
that that Lennon's success but that I
don't know it's it's a to try and get
clear on what the core of Marxism is he
souls Neeson's view I think correctly
you know characterizes as revolutionary
violence driven by Promethean rage
burning anger at the injustice is just
there that are all around us and this
rage aiming at utopian world free of
human oppression and division I think
the error of many is to say the key in
Marxist scream work of the Marxist
framework for dealing with this is his
account of economics and dialectical
materialism I think what Souls needs and
shows and what you if you study Marxist
comes out too is that Marxist ideology
is simply a tool intended to negate the
given and transform the human condition
he wasn't in other words he wasn't
attached that attached the particular
doctrines another commonplace about the
Russian or situation which became the
Soviet situation is well that's not
really Marxist because they hadn't
passed through all the stages of Marxist
economic development they hadn't fully
industrialized most Russians in 1917
like 80% I think were peasants living on
the way out and doing farming and but
Marx himself wrote a preface to the
manifesto where he said if you can have
a revolution in Russia this was in 1871
when there was much less industrialism
than there was in 1917 17 go ahead and
do it the point is to have the
revolution let's get that going let's
get that party started and drive that on
and of course in Marx he says it's got a
famous statement his theses on Feuerbach
the problem with philosophy prior to me
is that the thought has been you need to
contemplate or understand
world but the real point is to change it
so revolutionary practice revolutionary
change that's the key thing especially
revolutionary terror and other excesses
in the Marxist things like bank
robberies to support your work you know
Stalin kind of started off as a bank
robber for the Marxist all of this
aiming at eliminating everything private
I mean so everyone knows I think that
Marxist want to get rid of private
property in the ordinary sense you know
houses and things like that but it's
everything private that's the family
there's that that's a private
Association which separates human beings
from each other and hence is obstacle to
full human liberation religious beliefs
because having private ideas about God
and one's duties to God that can't work
Marx has got a really nasty essay called
on the Jewish Question where he explores
this at some at some length these things
all need to be eliminated allowing human
beings to become what Marx called
species beings and what he meant by that
is we would in the to borrow a phrase
from Bill Clinton feel each other's pain
you know that we once you've eliminated
those divisions between human beings
you'll appropriate each other senses so
private property the family religion
those they keep us from from being
properly sympathetic and compassionate
toward each other to really truly loving
and feeling solidarity with other human
beings that's the end goal of the
Marxist revolution that's something we
don't see today I mean if you think of
the you know the privileged movement
there's a lot of stuff about that going
on right and complaints about privilege
and etc etc but I can't really tell what
are you looking for you know a world
free of privilege you mean a world where
no one is better-looking or smarter or
more athletic or nobody gets old and
dies or I've got all sorts of defects
I'm gonna spare you my catalog but
they're just they're you know it's
that's the way human life is and baby
grab my glasses last night I thought oh
no she breaks these things I'm blind as
a bat
never get how will I get you know it's
you know now should i rage against God
for that I think that's kind of crazy
that's the thing you just deal with it
as best you can you know not Marx we
need to overcome those thing and then
all those evils will go away except
death he never wants to get into that
he'd never he never quite bring himself
to say people won't die anymore or what
about rejected love not that anybody in
this room has ever experienced that
right you know you love somebody and
they don't love you back and Wow how do
you deal with stuff like that those uh
that's that's there but that no we need
to get over that and we'll revolutionary
violence directed by a small party and
so Marxist like to talk about the
proletariat but in Marxism and in the in
a how it played out in the Soviet Union
the proletariat is literally depicted as
dirt that's that's a metaphor Marx use
inanimate matter that has to be struck
by the lightning of thought of the party
leadership that will guide it and so the
party is really the central thing that's
that's the they'll they'll provide with
linen called the guideline that's you
know that they'll tell you how to how do
house should go and the party rules in
the worst possible way by terror but
more commonly and perhaps more
importantly in some way by lies
radiology you know by they used to be
the statues in the Soviet Union of this
little boy who turned his parents in for
worshipping God and you know I can
remember his name is famous and the
regime's saying this is an exemplar this
is who you want to follow this is who
you want to to be and to elaborate a bit
on what ideology means because that's
least what it means for Souls and neaten
it means a doctrine and you could define
this differently so just the souls an
instant thinks which i think is helpful
I had to put this together I I thought I
knew what he meant by it so I was
preparing for this talk and I spent a
couple weeks putting things together in
various writings he doesn't a doctrine
at variance with reality that justifies
evil so it's not any principle or belief
some traditional conservatives will say
any apps
principals ruinous it's going to lead
you to the French Revolution it's bad
the Declaration of Independence is bad
what have you and souls in need since no
that's not that's not what I'm talking
about has to be incorrect it has to be a
lie you make people believe and it
justifies evil and that real effect of
this is to enable people to do
unspeakable things with a good
conscience and in the glory capella go
souls nice in contrast evil and
Shakespeare with ideological evil and
you know think of somebody ah go and
Shakespeare's Othello right I mean he's
a nasty guy
spreading dissension and but it bothers
him actually his conscience on dozen
souls and need some points off and it's
pretty lemon and evil and compare that
to a Stalin who kills millions and
sleeps like a baby because he's got this
theoretical justification in his mind
that I'm really doing Souls Neeson has a
beautiful portrait of Stalin in I think
it's chapters 18 to 23 of his novel in
the first circle where Stalin he kind of
thinks to himself as a suffering servant
he's like these stupid people I have to
keep killing them and selling them to
camps if they just do what I told them
to do I wouldn't have to do this and
it's such a burden being me you know and
it's it's a I think that's pretty darn
accurate but and so and of course
ideology in that case is not just
Marxist ideology it's any doctrine which
is a at variance with reality and the
you force people to adhere to and the
cause is evil it's a lie that is used to
justify evil I want to go on too long I
wanted to say something about the
positive teaching of souls in each sin
then what do you do with this though we
give this problem of ideology in terms
of statesmanship I want to say a little
more about stew leapin and the he's
clearly a model for souls and eats in'
he has I think it's chapters 8 and in
sixty to seventy three of August 1914
are all about stew leapin and what's to
weepin saw he really do try and condense
this down to key points his central idea
was the peasants need to be made part of
the country there
Russian peasantry lived in very harsh
conditions at that time they had been
emancipated from serfdom I believe in
1861 if memory serves but then they're
stuck in a sort of communal land
arrangement where there was no incentive
to be as productive as you could be
right that the think of Aristotle's
argument against communism and the first
five chapters of book two of the
politics we're not gonna care about
stuff that's in common for instance and
so still even saw that he's that we've
got to get the peasantry which was the
which had a lot of virtues was not
ill-disposed towards the regime didn't
hate the Czar but was treated pretty
badly we've got to help help them uplift
them into a better condition by granting
them rights
starting with here's property rights and
then moving to political enfranchisement
so a very hard-headed analysis that
people who had no experience of freedom
can't magically you're not gonna all of
a sudden have great democracy spring out
then it's not gonna work so but you can
begin moving towards that the other ways
you have to have the rule of law
so private property for the peasants and
the rule of law and that's a slogan that
gets tossed around a lot in America I
think still epin meant by that something
like what the founders are our founders
net protecting people's rights it's not
it's not merely a complex term of jargon
you used in Supreme Court cases just
very simply need to protect people's
rights and after the 1905 revolution
there was wave of terrorism across
lawlessness and still eep and restored
order and made a lot of enemies doing it
they probably executed about 5,000
people with summary court martials to
because it the situation had gotten out
of hand and the ordinary courts were
unable to do that but it looked like the
regime was falling and all of a sudden
it was back on its feet again and and
making reforms moving towards helping
the peasants still even also this was
defeated by the right he was hated by
both the left and the right
in Russia wanted to remove all the
political disabilities on the Jews in
Russia they'd been denied full rights
this was a was a real serious problem
that he saw and but that didn't work
because the right the right in Russia
said we can't change anything the left
said you have to change everything this
is really bad bad situation so he wanted
to leapin wanted to work within the
Russian Revolution you utilize these
these things what can we do instead of
impose an abstract model on the
situation once again something we'd be
well advised to think about boy that
seems pretty smart and the tragedy is he
was he was assassinated by a combination
a conspiracy from the left and the right
in 1911 and so one of the moral turning
points and he didn't die right away and
as he lay sick the Czar couldn't be
bothered to even visit him although he'd
been shot right in front of him and soul
Sinise and this transitions to my other
point you can't just have political
reform for souls in eats and he's famous
there's a famous phrase Neve archipelago
I mean if you might have seen to be if
you have read it that the line between
good and evil runs through every human
heart and his point is it doesn't it's
it's not classes it's not groups that
have privilege in our time it's every
human being has to struggle with being
good it's the temptation to do evil and
so the primary thing for souls in need
said yes politics is important good
statesmanship is tremendous importance
and it could have forced all the horrors
that came with Bolshevism but what you
also have to have is individual serious
about reforming themselves not passive
ops not passive objects that government
will take in hand and turn into
something they want and so he has a nice
short piece you could look this up it's
online even live not by lies this is
from the early seventies and this is
when things are getting a little looser
that not as bad as they had been and he
sits okay now it's things are loosening
up we can now concentrate
to stop lying and he meant individual he
didn't mean just the leaders line he
meant individuals have to start stop
pretending they believe this nonsense
ideology which is ruinous they have to
stop cow towing well there's always
rationalization for that right if I say
something I'll get in trouble I have to
support my family there's always reasons
for that and souls needs to saying you
can't have that you have to fight this
so this makes them unpopular with
everybody cuz of course if you you know
right and left want to say if you adopt
our program things will go well wherever
you're at I mean if that division
applies but and he's no you also have to
have this you have to have he says
especially and the fundamental human
characteristic he says in in this essay
repentance and self-limitation the life
of Nations is repentance that's that's
what makes us human more than anything
else our ability to see that we've done
something wrong and to his individual se
and his Nations - there's a national
duty we're not going to do that anymore
we're sorry we did it and not just say
you're sorry but don't do it anymore you
know stop it as much as one can you know
given human nature and the way it is and
realizing I've done these wrong things
where our nation has or what have you
then say what stop doing them let's
limit ourselves because usually these
things are excesses and eat especially
criticizes Russian imperialism and then
Soviet imperialism and since one of the
things Russia has to do to overcome its
past once they get through he thought
we'll get through this communist thing
but if we're going to recover from them
we have to embrace this idea non
imperialism you know we could talk more
about that in the Q&A if anybody wants
to flush that out you also have to have
a consciousness of God or you know and
he souls Newton himself was a practicing
came back to being a practicing member
of
a Russian Orthodox Church and he's very
cautious in his statements about what
people should do but it's from the
generic way you have to realize there's
a God is a higher being who imposes
limits on us that we're not in the
marxist phrase a man is the highest
being for man and that's one of the
things that allows all these
revolutionary evils to occur so we have
to get beyond that in his this you could
look this up online - it's a short piece
as opposed to the 2,500 pages of novels
on the on the first world war that his
Templeton address which his men have
forgotten God is the refrain throughout
that's what led to all these evils he
doesn't mean a specific if only we had
you know whatever version of
Christianity particular that he sees
saying I'm just God simply and and then
that unleashes the human will to do all
these sorts of evil things I'm gonna
stop there so we can have some Q&A and
yeah I look forward your questions
[Applause]
yeah thank you for your talk I'm just
curious
do you see anything in Solzhenitsyn
where he reflects on Russian culture as
being particularly vulnerable to this or
does he reject that idea that's a that's
a great question in he it's a great
question because he was really angry at
the standard line of American Soviet
ologist was Russia is a country that's
always had despots and if you guys ever
read George kennen's long telegram
you'll see that this is a view you find
usually in people like pipes and stuff
like that very intelligent people and
his argument is tonight the Facebook
status it's complicated
we had problems but we also have a lot
of resources that these people don't
acknowledge and and that there was in
some areas of Russia there was a long
history of local self-rule and local
self-government and his big political
hope he thought what you have to do
first is start with local
self-government you can't impose a
top-down he said we've done some of that
and sometimes in our history let's let's
try and build on that
also orthodoxy had been a great resource
and he points out you know the Russians
kept their character in their chin up
for 200 years under brutal Mongol rule
because of the Orthodox faith that was
much attenuated by westernizing reforms
put in place by the czars the
persecution of old believers and this is
too abstruse for you guys but Peter the
Great decided we've got to be more
Western and found a friendly patriarch
to help implement that and the people
that resisted were brutally brutally
persecuted people who you have to change
the way you make the sign of the Cross
you have to stop doing this
and so souls even thought this was a
contributing cost of world war one this
you know thing from the 18th century
because it's so spiritually Riven the
country but that's still a resource
that's there and and yeah so he thought
no Russia's not you we've got a lot of
bad things in our history that would
lend but we're not uniquely evil and
other countries have had their problems
too and we can you know we can do this
we're not doomed because of Russia to e
slavish and despotic I'm going forward
into modern times here how is this
synthesis of what you're talking about
here feed into what Putin is doing and
his and his ideas about Russia my best
here the I know I know quite a bit about
what Seoul's a nice and thought about
Putin and that's helpful in this it's
hard to get actual facts about what's
what what's going on in Russia because
journalism is mostly dead from what I
can tell like people going and what's
happening instead of opining we starting
with the opinion so souls and eaten took
his bearings on how to be Putin from the
disaster of the 1990s for Russia which
he really thought Westerners did not
appreciate the Russian regime Yeltsin in
particular took basically wholesale the
advice of their Western economic experts
and what that meant was the immiseration
of massive numbers suppose you need to
privatize and liberalize which sounds
great except what that meant was that
people who already connected to
political power just put their names on
the title deeds you might say and so he
he called it Russia's third time of
troubles and the other types of troubles
were times when basically there was very
little government and there was
widespread assassination clan feuding
disasters he says the 1990s so he said
Americans have to understand Putin is
going to be popular because he stopped
that so they can't they you know he
thought he had his defects but he said
look he's doing some good things one of
them was elevating the place of the
Orthodox Church and praising that and
doing things like this got runs counter
to many Western narratives the a
500-page of rich version of Garg
archipelagos required
in Russian high schools Putin you know
so they've set up places where their
perpetual prayers for the victims of
communist and recognizing that is evil
now Putin's not always good about that
sometimes he'll yeah it's really too bad
what happened after Stalin and Nick okay
how's that work so that's the the
downside there I think of how he would
evaluate that and and I'm speaking for
it he obviously can't speak for himself
at this point I think he would say the
problem with Putin is he doesn't view
the spiritual angle not merely religious
but the spiritual angle deeply enough
he's to his heart headed and has served
Russia well in some ways but in some
other ways it cuts off them the need for
that repentance and soft limitation
that's going to he would very much
oppose what we're doing in Russia's near
abroad and he was talking about that in
the 90s and saying America and the West
should let we need to sort this out with
the people's around this there's a long
history there and and so and he felt
that personally because his mother was
Ukrainian his father was Russian and so
he thought he didn't think the Ukraine
should be kept as part of Russia by
force but he thought we should really
try and make that work through you know
working this out amongst ourselves
because we have this long history
together you know so hope that was some
help yeah but really figure out what's
going on there I have a lot of students
last and what should I read about what's
going on in Russian look I don't know I
can't find it's hard to find there's if
you know Christopher Caldwell has a good
book out but it's hard to find it's hard
to find stuff what's just happening you
know yeah thank you yes my name is kami
Barton with the Pakistani Spectator and
my question is regardless what happened
in space Union in 1917 isn't socialism
has been part of human history from the
very beginning for example if you see
Jesus teaching or Islamic teaching they
always talk about a little man they
always talk about tithing and when Nixon
talked about you know the people who
have been forged and he was not talking
about white millionaire he was talking
about average you and more and similarly
our current president even he loves to
talk about little man even though he
himself as a billionaire surfer Thanks
yeah yeah yeah and this is a you know
I'll try SiC two souls in eating because
he's a lot smarter than I am he was no
fan of the Western capitalism he saw
because precisely he thought to put no
limits on acquisition if it did not
consider anything else and so I think
what he wanted was a concern and you
know you mentioned Christ you need to
inculcate a concern for others make that
an honorable noble thing to do to help
them to be a concern for society or the
common good in that way not merely how
much can I get
and and this really became obvious in
the 90s in Russia to him when the
capitalists who are not you know they're
not there's not type of libertarians
would like there they were there crony
capitalists right just plundered the
ordinary people and he was just furious
at that he thought that was a terrible
terrible evil and so he was willing to
give Putin a lot of credit for putting
an end to that and really helping the
ordinary person yeah so no there was no
and there has to be you know there's
different ways to do this but it can't
simply be I don't think and souls needs
and certainly didn't think self-interest
narrowly understood is my own
aggrandizement will just help everybody
else because there's always going to be
people that aren't going to be helped is
it not not just because of some
character defect even but the
differences in nobility all these things
you know the disability even all these
things age to not have a concern for
that one of the recent souls needs and
thought that Russia could repent was he
had done a lot of work historiography on
times when Russians were very forgiving
of things like their neighbors debts and
in the in the real sense of a debt like
you owe me money and okay but I'm gonna
forgive this because it's gonna throw
you out in the street if you don't get
it and you thought you know there's
something here in us that in the past
that we used to be able to do this so
you know hope that was helpful we have
time for one more question very
dangerous to historians Robin
history and I just want for the benefit
of the audience is the realpolitik of
the Russian Revolution so that we can
compare it to the whole theory of
Marxism Leninism sure number one the
Bolsheviks were financed all the time
for Western powers I was a political
project yeah you know the portion is
still 2007 90% of that Congress is for
in London and then when Russia joined
encanta and became an ally of Britain
there was no Bolshevik Congress for nine
years
mmm-hmm cuz nobody had to pay a bill so
all these ideology was absolutely
secondary financing was first second
when the Bolsheviks came back to Russia
after the February revolution they had
three slogans one was peace people he'd
won the war but the second was lent to
the peasants and the factories to the
workers mm-hmm so basically all these
people who fought on the side of the
Bolsheviks in this bloody civil war 90%
of them were peasant who be killed who
believed that they personally gonna be
enriched by stealing the land of
somebody else none of them was moved by
socialist Marxist latinus Bolshevik
ideology yeah they were all motivated by
personal profit because that's what they
were promised and the workers were
promised control on the factories which
they interpret again as personal wealth
sure sure so only after the Bolshevik
took the power and established the KGB
and the army and then they came back to
say well let me tell you now how we're
gonna build socialism yes I seem
important to be that a real of argument
made yeah I get that those I don't
disagree with anything you said and
actually in his work Solzhenitsyn he
spends a lot of time and gotten a lot of
fights with Westerners pointing out how
the Bolsheviks were especially through
this fellow taught with ties the German
regime parvis was a huge financier of
the Bolshevik movement and that the
ordinary people were motivated but I
think he would respond people like Lenin
the people at the top were very much
motivated by Bolshevik ideology but no I
think I think you're right about that
yeah and souls need some thought though
he agrees with that now
oh the idealist wanted to say no
socialism was chosen for he's like no
there's all these vulgar motors behind
it too so that's one of the major themes
of Lenin and Zurich actually is the
connection to Western powers that Lenin
had yeah first of all thanks for coming
all the way down to the swamp I wanted
to ask going back to human nature
what salsa needs and would think we're
doing from a domestic standpoint
specifically our government is doing to
try to distort human nature because
obviously I don't think we have a very
good understanding of what human nature
is from a cultural standpoint and from a
foreign policy standpoint we try to
impress democracy on people who may not
be so interested in it but from
specifically from a domestic standpoint
of policy speaking I think the probably
the greatest thing would be the
condition of the family which is you
know it was of course the family was
rent apart in cases where people were
sent to concentration camps but in his
work souls needs to spend a lot of time
portraying the negative effects on
family life in freedom you know which
meaning people who are not and those
those the attack on the family and and I
don't think there's an ax marks a space
attack on the family in America it's
because other other things going on
there they might be related I definitely
think there's an attack on a nature
going on there but the lack of concern
for children in their development so
that is really I don't think there's
more misery caused by anything in
America than no-fault divorce and I
don't mean to offend anybody who's had
it I mean I come from a home where there
was divorce and you know it's just I'm
not trying to say it's you know be judgy
to individuals but the the lack of
concern for right before I came to
Hillsdale I taught at another place and
was also worked in student life and you
know sometimes these poor college kids
would come in and their parents would be
getting a divorce and the trauma that
they
due to that I mean they did come apart
and I mean flat can't go from being
excellent students to and those are
these are kids are 20 21 years old and
very little thought for that is is an
example that comes to mind is if you if
you don't think your relationship with
your credit card companies working out
you can't unilaterally break it off just
because you think it's not very good but
marriage no no no no no reason needed
and that I think he would very much more
than anything else to Sapru but now
what's the solution whether that's
government intervention or say that but
certainly government could stop causing
problems you know I think would be think
something you would say he is the Soviet
Union began to wind down he could see
that he began to talk more about the
importance of education the family two
souls need synthesis to how are we gonna
recover from this and you can't
Moscow's not gonna solve these problems
you know so the same here I don't think
do you see can solve those problems not
because something wrong with DC or
Lansing or what-have-you but that's not
really how that works but but could stop
causing issues I think